we are back louder with Crowder I'm very
excited about our next guest because
we've had her on the show before but
only on YouTube on the web show I guess
you can say she caught a lot of flack a
neuro psychiatrist specialty it's very
specialized very brilliant lady doctor
Phyllis Boniface thank you so much for
coming on the show it's my pleasure
Stephen okay so you kind of felt a
little bit of the backlash of YouTube at
that point we did a video on marijuana
right when it was legalized in Colorado
and sort of examined where you are in
Ann Arbor the decriminalization and what
happens legally what are the
ramifications but I want to clarify
something in the video I didn't say the
government should be able to outlaw pot
in every state as a matter of fact I
take the libertarian stance if pots want
to legalize it fine the problem I had is
all the people who say legalize all
drugs legalize pot in order to get that
passed they generally aren't as
forthcoming about the harms of marijuana
and I think if you're an adult and you
want to harm your body fine but the
people who are wanting to legalize it
aren't taking on the responsibility of
assisting in education so that's what we
had you want to do which seems benign
enough right for you to say hey here the
ways pot might be bad for you and people
were furious did that surprise you
not really I've spoken at some forums
before it I know that there's a lot of
Pro marijuana people out there and I
always find it instructive to read the
comments and how people actually make
their arguments and people who are very
Pro marijuana and obviously heavy users
their their arguments kind of illustrate
the points that we're trying to make
that it can cause problems and deficits
and people's thinking
so it's Exhibit A exactly well it's
funny if you google right now you know
marijuana bad the first searches that
come up are people try and tell you
marijuana is bad but it's right-wing
propaganda so first off you yourself are
a libertarian right that's correct
except in the area of drugs okay except
in the area of drugs um and that's
obviously because you would probably be
more qualified than
be cherry 84 at yahoo.com commenting on
YouTube uh so I will tell you this being
raised as a millennial really in my
generation
we're raised to think it's benign it's
less harmful than alcohol right that
it's it's it's one of those things
people used to think was bad and it's
not anymore have you noticed that being
a trend right now with young people
where they're growing up just thinking
it's like smoking a cigarette absolutely
I think there's a greater perception
that it's kind of a harmless pleasure
and a lot of the young people that I
treat in my practice their high school
students or college students and they
feel it's like having a beer or two and
they actually don't they don't drink as
much as they smoke pot now that's what
they do when they go to a party on
weekends they smoke marijuana and so I
think there's a decreased perception of
risk and increasing embracing that
that's part of their culture
yeah yeah makes a lot of sense you know
I was raising in Montreal where it's
basically less than a speeding ticket
and this is entirely anecdotal I cannot
point you to one of my friends it was
very common but bortion of I wouldn't
say close friends people hung out with
smoked pot every single one of them had
some kind of a change in their
personality or their psychological
behavior by the end of high school and I
don't know if that's just me as a dummy
looking at my friend going you're pretty
smart in middle school and now you're an
idiot is is there some actual neurology
there that would that would back that up
well absolutely I would say in the
scientific world they always say you
know the plural of anecdote is not data
but we really do have data to support
your observations that a lot of your
friends who maybe started out with
promise didn't end up with their full
potential and that's the real concern
here because we're talking about
millions of young people who are using
regularly and I define regular use as
just once a week and and chillingly the
monitoring the future study here at U of
M shows that six and a half percent or
more of high school students are using
it daily
not just weekly so you know we're
looking at huge swaths of the population
not just a few friends it's becoming the
accepted norm
right now okay so you're talking about
people who are teenagers right in high
school to be fair if you're a healthy
adult let's say with no history of
psychosis or mental disorder if a
healthy adult were to smoke every now
and then let's say in their own house
I'm not endorsing this I don't do it so
please hold your your letters it would
be relatively harmless in comparison to
the developing brain right well I would
say that use in not youth and again we
have to define youth a lot of the
studies that have been done
prospectively
have been 18 and under but it's clear
that the brain doesn't finish wiring
itself till about 24 or 25 so a lot of
the studies now are continuing that that
observational study up until those age
groups so I mean it's speculation to say
that people over the age of you know
brain maturation have no deficits the
patients that I see of course they have
psychiatric illnesses they have anxiety
or mood disorders and a little bit of
marijuana completely you know throws
them into a relapse so mine is not the
typical population you know I do have
friends unfortunately professionals who
even physicians who smoke marijuana and
all I can say is you know I can see
subtle changes in their behavior when
they're using versus when they're not
but they clearly function at a high
level so we have to define also you know
when we look at IQ problems and we'll
talk a little bit more specifically
about that you know if you start off an
IQ of 137 and you lose seven or eight IQ
points you're still you know highly
functional you know versus the bell
curve of the population you know when
they lose seven or eight IQ points they
go from average to low average and
that's enormous ly consequential so
again it depends on the user I guess I
you know I didn't even really think
about that when you look at the bell
curve I am I took those online IQ tests
because I wanted to become a member of
Mensa only to do a hidden-camera video
with Mensa where I would go in and just
be like hey what if whatever one's right
what if we're all really just jackasses
who are self-important and I think it
was shy but like by like a couple points
so maybe it'll have the reverse
if I just smoke a doobie I can join
Mensa thank you you've convinced me dr.
Boniface I don't think anybody can
afford any few IQ points off the top all
right well let's get more into that
after the break here if you can stay
with us end up talked about specifically
how it might affect IQ and brain
development is fascinating stuff
dr. Boniface louder with crowder we'll
be right back we are back talking weed
with dr. Phyllis Boniface thank you so
much for staying with us and I apologize
for my hackish ness I can't be mature
when it comes to these serious subjects
I'm wildly uncomfortable with them so
you were talking about how marijuana
affects and by the way I want to be fair
here because a lot of people are going
to get furious online I feel like I
always have to preface it I'm not saying
that every state should just be able to
or the federal government should be able
to outright banned substances because
they're harmful okay that's not my
argument here I don't know if it's dr.
Boniface is we're just talking about
some of the information that people out
there might not have on marijuana um
so dr. Boniface before you were so
rudely interrupted by our sponsors tell
us a little bit more so about the IQ and
brain development and specifically what
can be observed
you know scientifically measurably with
with marijuana well there are a number
of studies some of them date back fairly
far to studies done in New Zealand and
in Sweden and in the UK that show a
decrease in IQ of up to eight points
there was recently a study release in
2012 of 1200 or 1300 prospective
observational studies on youth who
followed users of marijuana versus non
users and they found a decrease of about
six or seven points of IQ and this was
across the board even with people who
did not have any kind of genetic
vulnerabilities towards other mental
issues so um there was a higher
incidence of IQ decrease the younger the
person started using so if someone
starts using at twelve or fourteen the
cognitive deficits are much more
profound as someone who starts losing
using later in adolescents so again
earlier on
the neurodevelopment the more damaging
it is have you been paid by Big Pharma
to come on the show and spew this well
let's just say there's a huge pot lobby
if I really wanted to make money I could
work for them well you know itself okay
it's a fight you said because of course
I get accused anytime you disagree with
someone right it's a little bit
skeptical of climate changes but yeah
Big Oil it's like well you know what uh
big pharma right and we just wrote I
just wrote a piece it on theblaze where
a lot of people don't realize it the
biggest supplement companies which is a
huge scam by the way many of them are
owned by the big pharmaceutical company
so it's like I'm going to go holistic
and buy these vitamins and it's being
sold by the same person who gives you
your uh your pain killers um here's my
this is my uneducated you know mildly a
unintelligent brain working the idea is
Big Pharma has suppressed any and all
positive research on marijuana if people
go to the previous video they can click
the link right here if they're listening
to rest really go to ladder with credit
calm they say marijuana is actually
cures cancer it's very beneficial and
it's all suppressed by Big Pharma
because they can't patent it because
it's a plant so here's me looking at it
saying okay what's more likely all big
pharmaceutical companies since the
beginning of time have gotten together
and said hey marijuana is just
incredible wonder drug it'll put us all
out of business let's make sure to taint
all research when really one of the most
popular prescriptions is is my wife
takes is retinol it's it's a vitamin a
lotion so if they can patent vitamin A
it seems to me they could patent some
kind of a compound in marijuana and if
it were an incredibly effective drug
they would find a way to patent it and
just make money off of it is that my
stupid pea brain working or could it is
that a reasonable premise well that's a
basic economic Stephen and I'm sure you
understand if there's a useful molecule
in there they're going to find it they
would love to patent one of the
molecules in pot but the problem is
marijuana is not a drug I mean people
who make this argument can't even give
me a definition of what is a drug you
know a drug is something that's given to
a person that produces a measurable
effect in a measurable way and in this
day and age drugs are
they're actually engineered they're
single-molecule very elaborately
constructed that binds to specific
receptors in the body whether it's a you
know something for your hypertension or
it's something for your depression
whatever but it's it's very very
specific and even with that binding in a
certain area of the brain a single
molecule it has enormous effects pot is
not a drug it's 400 chemicals 60 of them
have actually been identified to be
active pharmacologically in the body and
some of them very psychoactive and it
also is highly variable you know there
are different compounds in THC and CBD
which is you know there's one of them
that can induce psychosis more it's it
gives the high and the other one has
more of a calming effect so I mean we're
not talking about a drug we're talking
about you know instead of a targeted
shot at you know at the brain it's
actually like buckshot it hits
everything this the cannabinoid system
links with every system in the brain so
you're basically talking about you know
I'm you know laser guided missile versus
a dirty bomb I guess that would be an
analogy yeah okay well it's just again
it's this is my my moderately
intelligent analogy who's trying to
understand the science of it and the
thing that really bothers me and this
this has got a frustrate you as a
libertarian right I have never once seen
and I am more of a libertarian too I
mean I think I'm more libertarian on the
idea of the drug war then than you are
but I don't work in it the idea that
these people who go out who want to
legalize drugs and they completely
absolve themselves the response they say
well it's bad for you but you know what
people should be able to put what they
want in their body I agree but if you're
the one who's pushing for it to be
legalized and in order for it to be
legalized you have to present some
logical fallacies like it's recognized
medicine or it's relatively harmless
I've never once seen a pro legalization
publication libertarian publication also
publish a piece saying hey here are the
harms that come with marijuana don't you
think it's their personal responsibility
to do that if they're going to be
telling people to light up well I find
it deeply
I think libertarianism is based on
self-reliance and taking responsibility
for one's actions and I don't see
anything more irresponsible than
leashing something into society that
will actually cause damage and impair
people's ability to be responsible for
themselves you know we have a vast
social net inist in this country and I
can tell you from experience I've seen
many people in the last 28 years
who are smoking marijuana their parents
are done disability because they have
drug abuse they're both smoking
marijuana now the children we have three
generations people on disability living
in the same home who are incapable of
taking care of themselves now that may
be the extreme but you know we have to
look at the fact that you know if people
don't function well society is going to
end up having to take responsibility for
them and that's antithetical to most
libertarians Wow I see how you tied that
back there intellectually very well done
doc um what about the people who just
say everything you're saying right now
there's nothing new it's just reefer
madness and you're just trying to scare
people
yeah well reefer madness is propaganda
I'm trying to tell people about
something scientific you know I
interesting that most of my leftist
friends you know they're big on
evolution you know and I always present
the argument well you know our brains
developed evolutionarily very very
specifically to do certain tasks over
thousands and thousands of years and now
we're going to you know we're going to
basically take a monkey wrench to you
know our evolutionary advantage in terms
of our ability to function as human
beings
well okay quick question there because
this is a something I show a lot of in
the last video the pro-pot people who
are by the way vastly outnumber the the
ante pots empty pot doctors like
yourself on YouTube who'd have thought
they'd say well actually the human body
you know these can't can't employed
receptors can employ I don't know how to
pronounce it receptors they were
designed for things like marijuana and
our bodies were designed to process it
and it's a natural substance that our
body expects as their in is there any
truth to that honestly well it's
actually opposite of that I mean we have
these receptors or else the marijuana
would have no effect if we didn't have a
reset
you wouldn't get a high off of it so but
that system is there for a reason and I
always say don't mess with mother nature
like that because that system is like I
said interlinked with everything mood
regulation cognitive function
impulsivity judgment all of these things
that are higher functions that are
required for you know our behavior in in
the world and and we're doing something
that will alter all of those systems in
an unknown uncontrolled way so well
there's a danger okay but what so but
they would say well why do we have those
receptors if we weren't designed to well
just cactus
well the cannabinoid system is
interesting it actually is part of the
stress response system of the brain so a
cannabinoid system when it's elevated
can suppress the stress response however
you can't do that willy-nilly you know
if you do that you're going to actually
change how the brain processes
information and behavior so you know if
you were to want to tap into that system
you certainly wouldn't do it in this way
we do it again in a targeted way the
stress response is critical for the for
our behaviors right well okay so that's
that's fascinating so I'm trying to get
my head around that because we do have
that system right that processes it
would it sort of be like saying okay you
know you have dopamine receptors it
doesn't mean that you should go out and
smoke crack even though that actively
you know reacts with dopamine receptors
it's not the right way to exactly I call
it a hijacking of the system okay you
know you're taking a biological system
that's there and has a homeostasis and
you're you're you're tapping into it and
altering it and what we call a non
physiologic way which means it is
causing that system to you know change
the complete balance put out too much of
something or too little of something and
change the regulation so okay that's the
problem so you don't smoke crack do you
doc no I don't I and unfortunately
anyone who smokes cracks usually going
back to it at some point so yeah happily
cul-de-sac evolutionarily well I'm just
saying people on YouTube the qualified
medical profession
those on YouTube do believe that you
smoke crack that's the only way you
could possibly be critical of marijuana
I just wanted to clarify that for our
listeners Thank You I wasn't sure it's
it's funny that we talked about this and
then and we'll bring you on after the
break cuz I want to get into comparing
maybe marijuana versus some other drug
specifically you know actually I guess
we can get into that now and then we'll
come back to sort of the social
ramifications so people would say you're
a psychiatrist right and psychiatrists
prescribe some what they would argue are
much more harmful drugs certainly drugs
that can result in death more easily
like adderall or certain antidepressants
what would you say to those to those
people who say hey these are these toxic
substances that psychiatrists push and
marijuana would be more benign yeah well
first of all the goal of psychiatric
drugs is not to get a high it's actually
wrong I mean people don't want people to
get a high you know that's where you see
the area of pain management is so
difficult because the therapy is
actually related to feeling a high and
that's quite problematic but in
psychiatry I mean all drugs are
subjected to double-blind
placebo-controlled studies which means
they have to be studied you know the
drug versus no drug they have to be able
to define a benefit and they also have
to define reduction or lack of harm it's
very difficult to do that there are a
lot of bars you know you have to you
have to jump over before the FDA will
approve any drug and now it takes about
a billion dollars of research and
development to develop a new drug to
bring to market so it's not an easy feat
and it requires sometimes you know
dozens of years of development to find
something that's effective and safe so
you know it's it's a very advanced
science in it you know in my practice I
do prescribe drugs but I always start
with you know do what's in the best
interest of the patient which means do
no harm we try to get people to manage
stress in their life you know get rid of
drugs and alcohol exercise take care of
themselves I mean that's always the
starting point we don't always prescribe
drugs right it sounds far too reasonable
for the land of the internet right now
but we'll bring you back after the break
and talk a little bit more about pot
doctor Boniface ladder with Cotter stay
tuned back
if paid off by Big Oil of course dr.
Boniface specializes in neuropsychiatry
talking about pot your brain on pot and
fascinating stuff so dr. Boniface before
we left we were talking about that you
know drugs and in psychiatry and how
psychiatrists are at least listen let's
be honest a lot of Psych crack
psychiatrists do push drugs as a first
line and and it's it's not right and
it's it's a rare case it's an exception
to the rule but let's also talk about
while we're discussing exceptions to the
rule you know this idea right now that
marijuana is not addictive and it's
certainly less addictive than something
like alcohol which is legal how do you
argue against that well I mean as far as
non-addictive 'ti I mean studies have
shown one in ten people who smoke pot
become addicted to it and if you started
earlier in life meaning in your teens
it's about one in six you know thirty
percent of people who use pot going to
use other drugs and that's not a small
number you know 50% of all addictions to
rehab and I do work in the drug
addiction area too
people started with pot use and
interestingly 90% of those people
started it in their teen years so again
earlier exposure increases the risk of
addiction vastly so 30% you said 30% of
pot users go on to use another drug
that's correct
now what about people who would argue
that has nothing to do with the drug it
has to do with the type of personality
who might gravitate toward pot generally
the personality who's arguing that point
in the first place yeah well we know
there are genetic predispositions to
addiction we think it has something to
do with the dopamine system and the
genetics that are inherited from your
parents so many people have a genetic
vulnerability but for example there's
also a genetic variability to mental
illness with use of marijuana and again
we've been working out the genetics of
that but the issue is that a large swath
of the population 25 or 30% are highly
vulnerable and they actually know this
there's a specific gene the COMT gene
it's called it has to do with dopamine
regulation
in the brain 25 to 30% of the population
has the variation that makes them
intensely vulnerable to addiction or
mental illness now is that a risk we're
willing to run is a population in terms
of Public Health well let me ask you
this because you say so 30% and then
your numbers are about 25 to 30% of
people have a vulnerability toward
addiction do you do we have any numbers
as far as what the percentage of people
who drink alcohol who either become
addicted or go on to harder drugs
yeah it's less than that and also I
wanted to find the difference between
alcohol this always comes up you are at
the ready with these answers I'm playing
you know I'm trying to stump you here
you know it's because these are
questions people ask me in my office
every day a lot of people are struggling
with you know substance abuse alcohol is
actually metabolized by the body and
your liver has enzymes a breakdown
alcohol it's been developed you know
through again thousands of years of
evolution you know this enzyme varies in
different genetic groups you know
Europeans break down alcohol much more
quickly than Asians and American Indians
they don't have as much of the enzyme
and the alcohol levels are higher in
these people so there's a vast
difference but we do metabolize alcohol
it's metabolized and excreted about an
ounce an hour of alcohol in general and
in European population marijuana is not
excreted in that way it's not excreted
period it's not metabolized it has to be
taken out of the body like a toxin
because it's it's a lipid soluble it
gets into the central nervous system and
it sticks there you know it takes five
to seven days to eliminate the marijuana
that's in a single cigarette and so you
smoke once a week basically THC is in
your brain exerting a pharmacologic
effect all week even though you're not
high and this is the problem it's what
we call a Depot drug so if you smoke
every day it takes 90 days to eliminate
all the metabolites of THC and that is
an amazing amount of time it's a very
very long half-life drug right so you
mentioned I'm trying to go back to some
of these numbers about people have a
proclivity toward addiction
well one thing that interested me was
remember the big bath salts care
remember that people are eating
everyone's faces off and stuff it was
after the chimpanzee and red wine and
xanax care which was the funniest of the
scares but so the bath salts scare I
remember when I actually read up on it
you didn't hear about this in the news a
lot the only drug they tested positive
for was marijuana yeah and actually the
you know a lot of the mask crime spree
people were heavy marijuana users in
their youth and did test positive right
now correlation doesn't equal causation
people that's the buzz phrase people
throw around online and sometimes it's
correct sometimes it's not so you know
not everyone who smokes marijuana
obviously is going to be a go on a crime
spree but is there any kind of data
there that would that would suggest some
kind of a correlation maybe with someone
who I mean how could marijuana trigger
someone to bite someone's face off let's
put it that way okay well I don't know
the details of that case but let's just
put it in the context of what we know
about the effect of cannabis on
psychosis for sure we can argue that all
of these people commit these horrible
crimes they're psychotic and they're not
touch with reality
you know there are many studies that had
taken place over the last thirty years
that show an increase incidence of
psychotic illnesses and people who start
using marijuana early in life you know
is it increases the incidence of
psychosis by about two to three times
over a lifetime really it also it
reduces the amount of time to the first
psychotic episode in someone who has
schizophrenia and that's not a small
thing you know schizophrenia usually
presents between the ages of 17 and 25
when the brain is fully matured and I
thought it usually presented itself in a
raincoat in an alleyway but continued
anyway when you reduce the age of onset
meaning instead of at age 20 someone
will start showing symptoms at age 17
instead so again these are people who
have the genetic predisposition they
follow them you know through their
lifetime and they find the age of onset
is much much younger in the first
episodes of psychosis people are
extremely vulnerable to doing
violent things the incidence of suicide
and homicide and things like that is
much much higher in those initial
episodes of psychosis so here we are you
know introducing a drug that may change
the age of psychosis reduce the age and
increase the vulnerability to that so
that's not something to take lightly no
it's not something to take lightly but I
do think there are a lot of people out
there you know and I will say listen I'm
just honest this is the only issue I
would say you know I'm pro-life I'm Pro
limited government
I'm not a big tax cut people know that
this is the one issue where I go back
and forth I think it really does come
down to states rights but I do you think
you'll have a large contingency of
people who say all of those things are
true but they also acknowledge heroines
bad and it should be legal anyway and a
big example they point to of course you
know as Portugal because they want to
end the drug war and I agree the drug
wars been relatively inefficient but
they say you know look at Portugal they
saved all this money in the drug war but
what I think a lot of people in a lot of
libertarians which you are again by the
way don't point to is that Portugal has
an immense public rehabilitation program
that's and it's entirely socialized
which would indicate that they've had
increased usage and addiction problem so
when people make the argument
economically right that everything
you've just said is true but it's still
not the government's role to go in and
tell someone that they can't do that to
their body where do you line up on that
as a libertarian but also a doctor and
again I think it comes back to personal
responsibility are you going to expose
people and again you know libertarians
assume that people can make rational
decisions they really they rely on
reason to guide their behavior and yet
they're going to introduce something
into society that we know will be used
by young people you know by example even
if we say they shouldn't be used by
people under the age of 21 it will be if
their parents are using it people learn
by example that it will actually damage
the brains of the generations coming up
now what kind of free society can we
have you know let me just be devil's
advocate here we're going to reduce the
IQ seven to eight points of you know
maybe thirty percent of the population
and we're going to be able to have a
functional
what do you really think it would reduce
the general IQ of the public or only
those with a proclivity toward problems
with marijuana
well actually the cognitive deficits are
not just in people who have a
predisposition they've actually looked
at this they they've taken out people
who have any kind of genetic
predisposition to mental illness or
addiction they've eliminated them from
the studies and even those people who
should not have the vulnerability or
having persistent cognitive deficits
these young people who start before the
age of 18 even after they're not smoking
for four to six months these deficits
don't go away now they haven't followed
them beyond that period but these
deficits are evident on neuropsych
testing which is really detailed mental
tests of tasks like memory and process
not to be confused with thetan testing
which if you're interested in
Scientology listeners and viewers I will
send you the kit continue dr. Monica so
in neuropsych testing and also it's
visible on functional MRI so we can
actually see a picture of the parts of
the brain that are involved in the
cognitive function that are compromised
they've shrunken in size their volume is
reduced the pathways between parts of
the brain are reduced and this applies
to anyone in the general pocket anyone
not just the vulnerable to mental
illness that's correct
now why okay let me ask you this doc why
is there such a pushback on this why do
so few people believe what you're saying
I mean if you could actually send me
these studies we'll get them up at
ladder with Crider calm so hyper like
them but why is it that so many people
are pushing back and saying that that's
just untrue that there is no evidence I
guess that there is no no data right now
that you you could draw those
conclusions that that happens that it's
all propaganda why is there such a
pushback and why do most people believe
that right now well I know about most
people you wouldn't find that in the
mental health community I don't know any
mental health people that really believe
that marijuana should be available to
people you know in the general
population I don't know some
libertarians are more like libertine in
my opinion they think anybody should be
able to do anything they want anytime I
mean you know come on
we have to have some kind of definitions
in society so the other issue here that
I find very interesting and I've seen
this in my patients over the few decades
I've been in practice marijuana damages
the prefrontal cortex that's the self
observing part of the brain that's where
we have insight and judgment and we can
see ourselves and how we function in our
behavior okay and people who can't see
themselves aren't aware of their
deficits if you know what I'm saying I
mean it sounds kind of circular you know
I work a lot with brain injured patients
as well auto accidents and when you
survey the families 95% of the families
who define that that person has serious
problems with their memory and their
functioning and they can't cope zero
percent of the patients saw it so the
inside part of the brain is compromised
they can't see it in themselves which is
horribly frightening that is probably
the most fascinating thing I've ever
heard on this show basically you're
talking about gosh so it so it removes
the self-awareness that would allow one
to critically observe changes in
themselves for marijuana precisely you
know I have some friends who are
neurobiologists and you know they call
the prefrontal cortex the seat of the
soul it's what makes you you if you've
ever seen someone with a brain injury
with damage to that part of the brain
and there are some famous studies you
know neurology studies that prove this
you change your funnel of you change who
you are so weird actually seeing damage
in that part of the brain again it's
evident on neuro psych testing it's
evident on fMRI which is functional MRI
it's evident on you know brain sections
actually postmortem so you know I don't
know what more evidence we we can use to
show that THC is neurotoxic and it's
neurotoxic and doses that are comparable
to using once a week right well if you
change the frontal lobe you change you
are you change my ear lobes you change
them I can get AM radio on these things
I've got giant ears but not to be mcgann
immature but I have to be because I'm
terribly uncomfortable with serious
subjects that really is fascinating to
me and I didn't really know that about
the frontal lobe but I will tell you
this I will have to go
do my own research because I know that I
don't know a lot about the frontal lobe
and what you're saying sounds reasonable
but I'm sure someone was a pro-pot
person could tell me something that
sounded reasonable with the frontal lobe
because I wouldn't be able to call them
on it so again we'll get this these
links up at ladder with Crider comm and
you can make your own informed decision
now final sort of thought here's the
thing you have to understand this is
broadcast on AM radio right the show
people are hearing it Michigan and
Alaska and few other stations who are
picking it up but it's really it's big
audience is online that's where we get
this is online if you look at the top
podcasts right now let's just say out of
the top 20 comedy or news and politics
podcasts people on there are all saying
marijuana is benign its proper you know
it's it's fine you can smoke it and
you'll be fine so those same people will
say well listen I'm not telling kids to
light up I think cars are great I don't
think a 14-year old should drive so they
create this this atmosphere where
there's a lack of responsibility right
where they say I'm saying that an adult
should be able to do what they want with
their own body I'm not saying kids
should use it but the ramifications with
society reflect that that is the case I
mean Ann Arbor is a great example right
that's where you are I don't know if
you've studied this but I have did you
have you studied the numbers as far as
once it was decriminalized in Ann Arbor
how usage increased among young people
well I know it went up tremendously I
don't know the numbers you I what we
actually included them in our last video
and I can get them up atletic I don't
have the exact numbers in front of me
but one thing again anecdotally we
actually interviewed someone who he
didn't include on camera but who was a
drug based old pot right and he said
yeah and then once was decriminalized I
said well you'd be out of a job because
the drug war right what if we legalize
all drugs all drug cartels would
straighten up and fly right and there
would be no more drug cartels they'd be
working at Denny's that's the idea and
he said no I just changed my business
model right it's more profitable for me
to buy from the Medical dispensaries and
I sell it to the high school by the way
a high school that is right around the
corner from you oh I know that I had
patients who were fell out of rehab who
were out selling and they were making a
thousand bucks a week you know it was
there it was their career I
when it became medically available in
Michigan there was a whole generation of
kids who were starting high school right
at that year who were had you know
increased impairments and a degree of
mental illness that you wouldn't expect
you know given their family history etc
and a lot of these kids just fell off
the grid I mean they dropped out of high
school and you know I don't know what
the stats are from the high school and
I'm sure in the educational
establishment they may track this you
know to see dropout rates and you know
maybe not going on to college that sort
of thing so the data will come
unfortunately it's going to be too late
for a lot of people right it might be
your kids it might be your siblings you
know and you know I mean if you look
back even it at tobacco you know we look
back now about how big tobacco pushed it
and you know was not you know all of the
dangers were hidden because there was so
much money behind it and now we look
back and think how evil that force was
well look what they unleashed into
society this horribly addictive
substance and it was you know it a lot
of things were not being brought to the
foreground that were they're probably
well-known at the time great comparison
people don't ever think of the big
marijuana lobby when it is absolutely
humongous a lot of people don't
understand that there are a lot of
people financial interest just like big
tobacco or just like big alcohol who
want to see it legalized and to do that
they have to in a soft way present it as
benign and harmless but we must go dr.
Boniface thank you so much for coming on
we will get these links up at ladder
with crater comm so people can make
informed decision and please come back
maybe next time we can talk about the
possible dangers of heroin will
speculate okay take care Steven thank
you doc hey if you like video check out
our previous interview with Gary Wilson
is poor and actually good for you or
check out this older video that we did
on marijuana if not you're probably a
sticky gross teenager in your basement
trying to excuse your poor habits